process of doing something you actually
like is my great addiction the fact that
I am able to actually wake up day in and
day out sleep easily for seven eight
hours a night and wake up genuinely
excited while always being prepared to
grab my phone and know that I have a
problem in my 300 person Singapore
office or something happened in LA or
one of the other 17 businesses that I'm
associated with are in trouble I sit on
top of almost 3 000 employees and two
very large businesses actively as the
CEO and then on the board of four others
and heavily invested in others and many
other things I'm involved with I have
plenty going on but the fact that I do
what I want to do enables all of it to
work this is grounded in something that
is the absolute answer for this entire
Arena the one thing I can absolutely
speak on that fundamentally touches
every person here is the relationship
between self-esteem and insecurity all
of the things that you do are based on
if you look at what's really been going
on with people for a very long time why
when one is sold fear that they believe
it versus when they're sold fear that
they don't why so few people have a
framework of believing in optimism
versus protecting themselves with
cynicism why people lack patience I can
tell you right now that for the majority
of people in this room that want
something to happen the biggest flaw in
their mental framework and perspective
is their lack of patience it is why I
make so much content around people that
are 22 25 35 40 and laughing and joking
and trying to some way somehow
communicate to them that they are
extremely young need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit on
my business partner I was making 300
bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the stories
for myself today too so today let's
learn from one of one of the best Gary
vaynerchuk and my take on his top 10 was
a success
enjoy
rule number two reframe success I think
it's really disingenuous to not talk
about the fact that a lot of people are
selling things that they cannot believe
there was a human being on stage
yesterday who said we believe that
people watch television
so that they can watch our commercials
[Laughter]
Remy not 1992 not 1982 not 1972 not 1962
not 1952 there was never a time ever
that people decided I'm gonna watch
leave it to Bieber just so I can catch
the Coca-Cola portion there was probably
and and I've done a lot of homework this
there was a time where the commercial
wasn't was a slight enjoyment part you
were curious it did have a different
culture the remote control had been
invented there was a lot more creative
fire more in the ad world in the 50s and
60s not because of anything but because
people actually saw the commercials thus
inspired highly creative people to want
to make them
and so yes I I do think that I mean I
there's people selling media
here that is not transparent media I
mean the the sh for all the
wonderfulness that is outside one thing
that is not outside in any shape or form
ever at can is common sense
no version of Common Sense otherwise
nothing that is being said would be said
and I think that the industry is within
itself I don't think we can go and
interview the 8 billion people on Earth
and ask them to recall four commercials
that they could today uh there is no
network television consumption going on
it's all gone to streaming uh and you
know yes I I really struggle with that I
I think it's incredibly challenging for
me to wrap my head around the concept of
selling something that in my soul I
don't believe in and I think that
happens a lot in our industry rule
number three be authentically you if you
if you pull a million people that have
ever heard of me and dug in a little bit
nobody's even going to be this is where
I'm complicated this is why I'm
attracted to people that are able to
decipher it this is how he Jim himself
got his job here trying to get a job
separately in vaynerx but I wanted him
on my team this is why I leaned into you
if one is in emotionally intelligent
enough with natural talent to have
figured me out I know they're an
incredible partner because I'm extremely
difficult because for all the people
listening right now that kind of know me
or have heard of me or actually
genuinely don't even love me that much
Laugh Love Like That is not that is not
love that is not what happens with me
when I go on stage or when I'm recorded
what comes out is Macho Man Randy Savage
promo videos what comes out is Chris
Rock and Eddie Murphy what comes out is
other things that influenced me in the
way that I communicate when a camera is
on me um
and you're still saying the same thing
it's just the way it's being said
totally and and that that's yeah it's
funny I don't know if you guys saw it
I've seen this at all lately out of
nowhere I've been for the first time
ever thoughtfully trying to tone down my
energy and my speed and communicating
not because of anything else out of pure
curiosity back to what we were talking
about testing stuff it's been really
fascinating just a 10 off the pedal
is just such a different thing in
watching the audience consume it now I'm
gonna still go 150 because it's just
where my natural thing is and again when
I go 140 I'm missing that person who
needs 147 who almost nobody else right
now can get to yeah and unfortunately
the only people that can get to the
person that's at 147 are the bad guys
and gals yeah got it absolutely got it
that's it I have come to realize my
place in this Avengers role is I'm gonna
have to eat judgment from people I
admire
to get through to people
that are only getting influenced by bad
because the other Goods don't have that
one gear that I have that Cadence that
style
and I'm willing to deal with the
ramifications
to achieve the actual good goal rule
number four find real happiness I've
been thinking about something a lot
lately which is
a lot of my friends and acquaintances
always ask me why I go so hard why I'm
pushing so hard
you know because I'm very fortunate at
this point in my life that I've put some
wins on the board I've achieved a couple
of things it always reminds me how
surprised I am
when people ask me this question it
reminds me how many people genuinely
believe that financial status is the
North Star
their question is almost always baked in
the framework of how much money I've
acquired or have
and I always ponder that it's always so
interesting to me how the data the math
is black and white on this issue
there is absolutely no correlation
to one's wealth
that Maps their happiness this is black
and white we continue to have a world
that is confused that money buys
happiness it continues to be what
someone who's hurting thinks is the
potion or the anecdote to fix it
yet we have unlimited amounts of
hundreds of millions of people who prove
otherwise
we must start there
the concept that you're gonna buy your
way to happiness is the biggest falsity
in human society and we must stop doing
that also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five believe in your
dreams at 22 the only thing I wanted to
do was build my family's business for
them
and I was kind of like the talks I was
having were weird which is like you're
gonna give up the best years of your
life for your parents because they did
it for you and like I have like this
altruistic like noble like family
immigrant vision and I was psychotic
about it and like literally did not like
like actively tell people like I went to
everything is best in Balance like it
would have been okay if I went to the
Jersey Shore once in my 20s it would
have been okay but I didn't that's how
psychotic I was I think but
the reason I'm so happy is because I'm
going to give you the answer of what
ties that together which is the only
thing you should be thinking about is if
everything was perfect
like as if I was a genie from the future
and can grant your actual wish you have
to try to make that actually happen
meaning even if you've never said to
your dad only to yourself not even your
best friend like if you've said to your
own self that I want to be an actress or
I want to be a doctor or I want to be a
Supreme Court Justice or an entrepreneur
whatever that is whatever it actually is
that's what 22 to 30 is about
it's all high risk it's the biggest
falsity that has been sold to kids now
you've got to actually know what the
[__] you're doing as if you're actually
in the best position ever to execute
something that's not practical
you don't need a lot of money to live
you can live with 40 of your friends let
alone three you could you can eat like
in your 20s so you can buy Dollar Food
and like you can just you don't have
kids you don't have you don't oops sorry
uh you know you are you are in the most
practical place from 22 to 30 to do
crazy action but the world has taught
kids that that's the time you're
supposed to have it figured out it's
insane so my advice to you is whatever
your biggest single dreams are that
you've kept to yourself have been scared
to even think you could you've got to
challenge yourself to try and that looks
like this whatever I just said if it is
Supreme Court Justice it's interning
it's paying a law firm even though you
didn't go to law school to like be an
assistant like people understand how
life actually works like if you could
just get into the game weird things
happen
right if it is Hollywood life like you
need to move to LA and like like work
for like it's working for free
which comes in all shapes and sizes your
dad is a successful business person you
might be able to afford to work free and
that's okay that's like family Dynamics
work for free is also working at safe
Ryan Reynolds worked at Safeway that's
working for free that's nine bucks an
hour like you know that's the that's the
theory right like it's zero if you're
miraculously in that situation most
people aren't some are it's okay my kids
will be for example it's okay or minimum
wage but in the thing
or a job that gives you plenty of hours
to be in the thing I tell a lot of
people who want to be influencers to get
like a job at 7-Eleven and just make
content all day while they're standing
behind the register
like you know I'm like get a job that's
not actually making you do anything so
that you have time to do the thing
that's true I mean I don't want to think
what people are doing right now that I'm
paying them you know like you know like
so you have to go for your actual dream
the one that scares you the most because
it's the one you want the most but you
haven't even thought you had a chance to
do it
it's it actually makes sense this is
what why I'm so passionate about it if
not now when
but but the world really everybody up
like this concept that you have to now
you went to college and you thus now
know what the [__] you want to do who
show of course ironically orthodontic
Doctor Lloyd yes of course there are a
small group of professions that the
passion in the school and you know for
everybody else
nobody's doing the thing what exactly
and that's where everybody is and and
you guys have know your options you have
so many options because of Technology
but the real answer to your question is
the dream that you haven't even
felt comfortable believing in rule
number six focus on the positives to
your point I genuinely believe the
reason I can take the feedback is
because when I go into my Instagram post
that I just posted literally in back to
back content comments excuse me one will
say that I'm walking on water and the
next will say that I'm a snake oil
salesman charlatan the fact that neither
penetrate my psyche is absolutely where
I'm at um absolutely and that's
Equanimity right like that is that
whatever you want to call it it's the
game because people want the positive
reinforcement uh you know there's so
many models on Instagram right men and
women you're so beautiful you look so
great you're so beautiful you look so
great you're foolish you look fake
they're crushed because they take too
much yeah and that you look so great yes
and I think and I think that's the point
that we're hitting on here which I love
is that that over emphasis on positive
it's what makes the negative so hard to
take it's also an incredible place for
me to add some clarity that I haven't
done a good job on historically which is
something I'm thinking a lot more about
ragoff it's fun to see you here because
yesterday I'm like look I'm at my worst
when I'm excited in an interview and I'm
and I'm drilling a headline because I
love doing it it's fun it's Showmanship
it's wrestling promo videos it's my
natural state you know I talk a lot
about not giving a [__] about other
people's opinions
it's also because I take the complete
opposite approach which is every
negative piece of feedback that I get I
genuinely go into two places a I deploy
sympathy and empathy for the person
leaving the comment because inevitably
immediately on that action I know that
they're not in a good place if you go to
somebody else's social consume it and
then spew hate you're not in a fun
you're not in a good place no absolutely
you're unhappy yeah next I start trying
to see the insight to any truth in it
you know the second that you're high on
your own Supply You're vulnerable yes
and so I don't I don't give a [__] about
anybody's opinion ironically I value
everybody's opinion I just synthesize it
and then decide to take the good from it
yes by deploying empathy and sympathy to
the deliverable I'm stunned by our lack
of conversation in society right now on
this part there's a lot of judgment and
hot takes and comments we need to judge
the person delivering the message
absolutely
like like how is your mother's opinion
of you have the same weight as Anonymous
54's comment on Instagram yeah that is
ludicrous absolutely in the same way of
how does a co-worker's opinion you have
to factor that in different than your
mother because your mother blindly
thinks you're the best if you're lucky
enough to have that mother you know and
so
super fast it's it's just pulling from
opposite directions and I think you know
I'm pulling so hard
from opposite directions that my balance
is coming in that rule number seven
practice gratitude the number one thing
that I'm completely convinced would work
for everyone the only thing that I'm
convinced would work for everyone it's
hard back to everything we've been
talking about because it doesn't come
natural to most people
but it is the ritual is practicing
gratitude every morning
so I don't meditate or pray per se but
there's not a morning that I wake up in
the world where when I wake up including
the overnight flight
where I don't look at my phone
immediately you know a lot of people
like to wait to look at their phone
which I love you know remember when I
said and not or one of the biggest
reasons the world has conflict is
people keep telling people what they
should do
right like I'm very happy that
meditation works for you it may not work
for someone else you can recommend all
I'm doing up here and saying hey think
about this
but I don't judge anybody when they
don't do what I do or what I hope they
do I want it for them but for me every
morning I grab my phone right away and
if nothing horrible happened
and I let this be very clear nobody died
of the 10 people I love the most
if nothing horrible happened I am
actually incapable
of being upset during the day
I could be frustrated
I could be perplexed
I could be for a second upset
but
I just don't know how to be upset about
anything
other than someone you love dying
I just don't think you should rule
number eight ignore the opinions of
others let's talk about why
actually listen to somebody else's point
of view on your life
let's talk about why somebody else's
point of view on your life is something
you're willing to accept
I am fascinated by people's ability
to take strangers comments
on a social media post
and allow it to make them upset
you post something
and you're happy to post it
and then somebody literally leaves a
comment
that you're unattractive you're stupid
like literally high school and Junior
High teasing
and your entire day
sometimes weak
sometimes month
is completely ruined
by a human being who is on the other
side on their phone
who is hurting so much with their own
life that the need for them to make it
palpable is for them to take time to go
to other people's lives and try to tear
them down
to make themselves feel better
this is what I call
foreign
I call a circle of insecurity
a circle of insecurity
the concept
that that is happening
is not Facebook's fault
is not Instagram's fault
is not tick tock's fault
it's not we have become infatuated
with blaming the platforms
for our own shortcomings
until humans
decide to lean into accountability
and stop blaming platforms and
politicians
people will continue to be unhappy rule
number nine take accountability I want
to remind people you're in control yeah
it's incredibly important and
appropriate and I appreciate especially
being very cordial for people to ask and
things of that nature but I want to
remind people they're in control yeah I
want to provide value and put out things
in my professional career I'm incredibly
private and feel that the world is
entitled to what you give it
so when I watch people get upset when
people get into their business I'm like
you're giving them your business by the
way you're leveraging your business
I don't want to leverage nor give my
personal life to the world
I don't think that's the right way yeah
by the way yeah I just think it's my way
yeah
um so the reason I have a little bit to
what you're referring to is it became
not sustainable because it's been a long
time and like I was in a Transit like it
just it was the appropriate time yeah
and I needed to just get some context
out there but I'm uh it's not where I'm
gonna go yeah and that's what I was more
interested by to me it's not listen us
being together my brain goes into
maximize the value
at the highest levels because we have
the opportunity to for as many people
are listening the takeaway there from my
perspective is you're in control yeah
you have a learning disability and you
want to share it Mazel Tov you don't
great yeah it took me back to something
less serious it took me 15 years of
public life to say I'm not candorous and
it's hurt me my personal life
and it's hurt me in my business life
you get to share what you want to share
yeah and and I think people should be
careful of what they share yes you share
your abs as a like a like you're a good
shape dude people are going to talk
about your body for the rest of your
life yeah
yeah but you did that you're gonna show
your kid all the time they're gonna talk
about that relationship they're gonna
talk you're giving the world permission
yeah I prefer not to give the world
permission because that's a sacred place
for me yeah you know even look at my mom
she like the greatest gift I could give
to the world is my mom to the world the
greatest
she's Alpha me
she's more experienced she's a different
perspective as a mom as a she doesn't
want it the end right I thought my dad
and mom would be reverse my dad I never
thought would love the Limelight so much
um but you know so I think if you're
listening right now please if you're not
going on social media because you have a
skeleton in your closet
you have a disease you have a bad you
know situation you uh you're like me and
like grew up in a family where like
personal life is private that's I think
you know in Russia that was like people
would go to jail if anybody knew
anything about you so I think it
ingrained in my parents which then
ingrained in me and my sister and
brother like we're private that way
um you know I think you have to
understand you're in control Facebook
and Tick Tock and podcasts and YouTube
don't make you do anything yeah they
don't make you do anything I'm so glad
you're dressed up because I think
there's and this is why I brought it up
I think there's been a mask of false
vulnerability that's been encouraged
because of social media so people think
that the more vulnerable or more open
sure that shows authenticity yeah I love
you for that you're going to a very
smart place I would argue I see more
lack of authenticity in the way that
people are leveraging their family and
personal life because they know it does
well I think the lack of accountability
is leading to so much unhappiness
like life is so much better when you're
like this was my fault yeah absolutely
control yeah and so like you know this
was like a wrap up to control you're in
control you you decide what you consume
you decide what you believe you decide
who you surround yourself with you
decide what you put out take on
accountability yeah everybody wants to
blame right now the algorithm they're
acting as the algorithms are like
hypnosis and I understand endorphin hits
and all that but like you can delete the
app you can
like where is accountability in this
yeah right yeah absolutely no we have
alcohol we have tobacco we have drugs we
have weapons and we have all sorts of
issues but most people play Within
moderation that's on you yeah and it's a
tough truth right it's a tough it's a
tough it's a tough truth especially when
you're unhappy yeah yeah that goes back
to why it's important it's like the
chicken and egg it's like working out
like I got into better shape the last
eight years nothing comes less natural
to me yeah nothing comes
right like but like I was like I just
would like to live longer yes I would
just like to live longer yeah and
go figure it's not apple cider gummies
it's not steroids it's not implants I've
thought about I'm like can I get chest
implants I put in a lot of work I feel
like I've got like that's good like I
feel like but like my body type like you
know and I'm like I probably haven't but
uh but but no it's like eat well go in
the gym yeah do the right things and so
same for life you know whether it's
meditation whether it's exercise whether
it's therapy whether it's good
conversations whether it's surrounding
you know you know back to us not having
the center you know we've had some meals
we've had some interactions they're
always like they're nice we need more I
would like that yeah and we'll build on
that I think you know I I'm spending
more time thinking about
spending more time with more while
doubling down on core you know yeah yeah
you know because I've been I did a
really good job in the last 10 years of
doubling down on core
but but I think being as busy and I love
what I do
you know I really do want to build out a
more of a friend Network more I want to
take more people from
lightweight acquaintance to solid
acquaintance I want to take people from
acquaintance to friend from friend to
best friend and so I'm on a journey like
everybody else but I think that um
God God I think believe it or not this
is going to sound so crazy for so many
the world actually has so much potential
for everybody listening to be the best
time to be alive
medicine and technology and there's so
much but we're caught right now it's
like a hamster wheel we're in the
momentum of focusing on
you know the bad yeah and there's
there's always bad yeah the the
Holocaust was bad
genocide is always going on Genghis Khan
was not a fun time to be a human yeah
like you know like we we are very bad at
history I was a really bad student but I
did well in history like but that starts
with you what are you gonna do about it
because right now everyone's like
pointing and feels like it's on someone
else yeah it starts with ourselves I
know number 10 the last time before some
very special bonus Clips is be
optimistic I hope everything is good uh
uh one random thing like it's been
really working in my community uh just
call somebody you haven't talked to in
two years just literally go to your
phone right now contacts hit the letter
C the letter F you're gonna see somebody
from high school somebody that you used
to date and you're over it now like just
literally call somebody call not text
call somebody and just say what's up I
hope everything's good and like that's
it like even if you hang up after that
like
get you know like exercise like eating
getting into practice of optimism and
positivity and good matters so randomly
just call somebody and hit me up on
social let me know how it went like but
this is crazy I do this once in a while
in my world like people have called
their father estranged father for 15
years their best friend that they just
both got busy and now they're like back
and their families are friend like this
it's crazy
I think one of the most important words
for me to communicate in this talk today
by far is patience I promise you no
matter what you're doing in this room
and especially as I look around this
room first of all everyone's
uncomfortably attractive and number two
and number two but more importantly this
is quite a young audience and I think
the reality is
the thing that I spend most of my time
on is trying to get people to understand
that patience is a very important
variable of success and more importantly
that I believe the far majority of
people in this room do not have a great
relationship with time
I am fascinated by people in this room
who are stressed at the ages of 18 and
22 and 25 and 29 like the Running Out of
Time how many people by show of hands
are under 30 years old
all right
so for me as you can imagine
when I see all those hands go up you can
put your hand down
yeah you're good okay good
when I see all those hands go up and I
know in my mind with the way that modern
medicine and technology is going that
the far majority of this room is going
to live for another 80 years
it really gets me
excited slash concerned when people want
their business to be huge next year
the quicker you want it the more
vulnerable you are
vulnerable you are and what has been
very fascinating for me is even though
on YouTube and Instagram and maybe some
of the places you guys see me maybe my
energy is high maybe my style of
communication is fast but my business
actions are extremely slow I was a dnf
student
I uh I sucked at school like I got like
I actually was so bad at school that I
had my my admin my my assistant reach
out to my high school and get a copy of
my report card so I could put on
Instagram the other day because people
are confused what success looks like or
how you get there doesn't mean that you
should look at me and not do school it
means that you need to look at yourself
and figure out who you are what are you
good at what do you like how are you
going to get to the place that you want
to get to and so for me I got four A's
in high school in my entire career all
in gym right like I got a D in yearbook
you know and so to me there's just a
thousand paths out there and so for me
I'm curious about one by one one by one
for the 30 people in this room where's
their mindset where are they at who are
they listening to what are they judging
their self-worth and their ambition
based on how are they counting the
points because when you're youngster
you're looking at all sorts of different
things you're being affected by all
sorts of different voices and for me the
only thing that worked even though I was
getting D's and F's and all my friends
parents told me I was a loser even all
my teachers told me I wasn't going to be
anything even though I didn't have stuff
even though I was I just was in my own
head I knew exactly who I was but the
thing that I was willing to do was I was
willing to work
and the thing that my parents taught me
was not to dwell not to cry about it I
didn't have when I when I rolled up on
my mom when I was nine when Nintendo was
popping because then when it first broke
I was like Mom I need Nintendo she's
like good go get it and so I shoveled
snow and
I ripped people's flowers out of their
yard and sold it back to them
which is my favorite one I think again
what I'm really trying to establish in
this talk this afternoon this morning is
I don't think people have Quantified the
opportunity
I struggle regardless of circumstance
when with people dwelling or complaining
in a world where the internet is free
has no idea who you are could care less
it's right there and it becomes a game
of skill not necessarily finances to
actually win
it's interesting to me it's interesting
to me that you can be in the retail
business
overnight by setting up a Shopify
account which costs nothing
when that same action to sell something
30 years ago meant that you had to sign
a lease and build out a store and rely
on the local traffic that walked by it
scares me and excites me that the
biggest Music Company in the world
Spotify was built in Sweden by a kid and
on and on and on and you've heard every
story
but more importantly for every
ridiculous story we've seen of Instagram
or Facebook or Uber or Spotify there are
hundreds of thousands of stories of
people with wins that are micro versions
I actually think the most unhealthy
thing in entrepreneurship and
opportunity is the big stories that
everybody thinks they have to build a
billion dollar company
I think we do not talk enough about the
Practical 150 000 a year three hundred
thousand dollar a year 700 000 a year
business that you genuinely love what
you do
and you can live your life being happy
and financially sound and what the cost
of Entry to be able to do that is in
today's environment which once again let
me say very slow
between putting out a media company if
you decide to put that on a WordPress or
a Squarespace a retail company
on a on the back of a Shopify you could
start a radio show that is global on the
back of just uploading something you
record on your memos
on your phone and upload onto Spotify
and apple and SoundCloud my friends
distribution is free
yeah
I know it's a nerdy thing like it's not
like some big profound statement but let
me say it nice and slow
distribution is free it used to cost a
fortune
now what you put inside of it is the
variable of your success not your
financial capabilities to create the
distribution
I wish we could zoom in I literally have
Goosebumps on my neck right now
no but really I really do it's like a
very I I I will live my last breath
trying to
get people to understand this is
remarkable
this is this is a game of perspective
are you educated or capable of seeing it
from the lens that I'm speaking about
today which is the barrier to reach the
end person whether you're a financial
advisor and trying to get to a client
whether you sell bow ties whether you
want to be how about the fact if you
want to be a professional football
player and now there's all these
websites where you can upload your film
because the Scout didn't come to your
tiny tiny town and now you actually can
be discovered
like everything has changed my question
and my dream every time I speak is can I
get one person in this room to get their
peace I think you should invest whether
it's you or the person below you but no
further than that over a hundred hours
of qualitative consumption of every
personal brand trying to convert on
Facebook Instagram YouTube to just see
if there's anything you see
one of the biggest mistakes that one of
the things I've never talked about that
I'm starting that literally this might
be the first time I'm talking about this
what's good about two weeks vacation you
get the thing like I don't I don't know
if I'm articulating enough to people how
much research I'm doing
I'm just now I'm doing it with audience
I'm not seeing what you know Richard
Branson's doing or other I don't do that
I just consume everything my audience is
doing with me
everything
all of it I just I'm just reading all
the comments I actually like losing more
than winning I've come to learn this is
something I'm really trying to reconcile
I actually like losing more than winning
it speaks volumes to why I'm obsessed
with the Jets and nicks and completely
have abandoned the the Yankees and the
Rangers after they won a championship I
like losing more
micro losing or macro micro losing but
Micro but everything is micro losing
besides death or bankruptcy
yep
like I just don't give a [__] what you
guys think
and that goes from you all the way up to
my parents
that
by recognizing that you guys don't have
that nor my parents has all the context
nobody fully knows you
it's actually through empathy
what age was that like
early
early like I can't believe how I now
understanding a little bit more back to
like being in your own cocoon I don't I
can't believe the mentality I brought
into high school like to navigate High
School the way I did which is like
completely and utterly not affected by
peer pressure in hindsight
is wild to me that takes a level of like
self-confidence at such an early age
that I think I just understand so much
more of what I am now really on that
window because that is such a tough spot
and um
that do you attribute that to your
parents and the work from a young age or
yes
DNA my parents gave me clearly the way
that my mother raised me
um having to earn my keep
and then just like DNA man just like
that voice that we all have like
I just always felt that I was better and
here's where it gets really good but if
the world showed me I wasn't like I
remember going through this is actually
interesting I don't know if I've ever
shared this I remember vividly going
through the ages of like seven to like
being stunned anytime I didn't win in
something
like shocked
like just could not believe that
Rick was better at tennis or John just
beat me in one-on-one or I wasn't the
fastest in my class or like just shocked
and you know and I've been thinking
about that lately because I just it
sparked me a few months ago I'm like
wait a minute that was weird what was
that because I you know I just kind of
remembered it like sha I remember
actually what seemed in my mind as a
disappointing thing at the time and now
I look as a great thing I remember
thinking somewhere around 13 14 15 that
I lost my expectation of always winning
in everything every time
and I remember thinking like that wasn't
good but in hindsight I think it was
great because the reality is I got into
this place of complete and other utter
confidence
but being able to not come up with
excuses if it didn't work out
like watching people like lose and then
blame the Sun
like literally like what like I
overheard it a couple weeks ago
somewhere uh I was walking like like oh
I'm on vacation I overheard it like this
kid lost to his cousin it looked it
seemed to me they didn't look like
brothers uh and he was blaming the sun
and it took everything I had to not like
roll in and be like bro I love you but
like you need to realize like the sun
was there for him too and I think I
think a lot about that accountability
like if you're coming up with excuses
like being super confident filled with
excuses when it doesn't work out is
called delusion
so
I feel great because I love process how
do you speed up things less rules
how do you speed up things less process
how do you speed up things less fear you
know so you know this is something that
has been my calling card for 20 years
and it is out of it is out of complete
and utter lack of fear complete and
utter disdain for process
that is in the mix for the sake of
process obviously some process is needed
um and this is ultimately was the first
reason I got into culture besides
having good DNA about liking people it
was that I understood that if people
were motivated and excited that great
things would happen versus fearful and
political
um the type of leader that will create
this is one that really focuses on those
three things that I just mentioned I
think people have now aspired to be an
entrepreneur when they're not and those
are the people that are going through
depression are suicidal are unhappy
because they're in a game that doesn't
match them
so when I say that it leads I'm playing
chess it's never a one-size-fits all I
want to see what the person says next
I'm looking for the tell
got it brother yeah I'm like you know
well listen don't over stretch you got
patience your 20s is a good high risk
High reward time if it's in you like if
you said that to me if Gary said to Gary
yo go to Europe go this I'd be like [__]
you all right me too me too well that's
what I'm looking for okay because when
the kid says yeah you're right I'm like
uh-huh
and I couldn't breathe
I had to I had to do it every second I
couldn't breathe this is when you're a
natural purebred you're in Beyonce
LeBron Pablo Picasso category you're an
artist
you're an artist there was no choice I'm
not doing this for the
Flex or the gram or the money or the
house or the jet or the I don't want a
single thing I don't want to be part of
any exclusive Club I don't need an
island I don't even how I need the game
yeah game sales and marketing is mixed
that means you're actually doing sales
and if marketing is put into a place
where it's all upside
because marketing is gray
it is intuitive right so if if the rule
is 500 000 I'm just I'm making it up and
like there's no like at the end of the
day it's like if you were the head of it
for me I'd be like it's 500 000 and my
team will tell you this
James will definitely tell you this it's
like I don't give a [__] we'll talk at
the end of the year explain yourself but
I have no judgment I'm not booing or
cheering along the game just tell me
when it's triple zero and explain to me
why we lost 112 to 88 or why we won 112
to 88 and you just hold that person
accountable that's how marketing needs
to work because that's marketing you
have to be able to do something
ridiculous like buy fifty thousand
dollars worth of bananas and send them
to dentists just because it's so
ludicrous that they're like what the
[__]
you see where I'm going now like like as
as silly as what I just said to you you
you would be shocked how smart what I
just said actually is based on how silly
it sounds the world is busy
yeah the way you break through is by
breaking patterns if you're a dentist
and you get a banana sent to you in the
mail and you wrote a note on it in pen
that's just weird weird enough to give
you awareness other people I'm watching
here are 24 and are regretting already
I'm like okay I need to help them think
about this because that's a bad
framework because if you regret if
you're that insecure if you're that if
that's your perspective then you have no
right answer
because if you go and travel and you're
34 you're whatever you are financially
or professionally at 30 40 you're like
I should have worked more Argentina if
if you know or if you do the other thing
and you work your face off you're like I
ended up just like Gary all my friends
had fun and yeah I got a million bucks
at the bank but I'm sad because I wish I
went to the
Beach more often so so either you're in
that framework or you're not which is
which is a great way to put a bow on
everything I've been telling you you
want to blame other people the
government Google knock yourself out you
will go to the Grave blaming somebody
for something let's come out of this
leaning into humility and gratitude and
that will be the springboard to
everything you want if you can like just
be grateful yes you lost your job or
your business not as good but your
grandfather didn't die from Corona you
know just be grateful like grateful for
the time you're spending with family now
grateful for the Innovation time the
thinking time I'm sleeping more than
ever I put on a couple pounds so I gotta
be a little bit more careful but I'm
gaining real muscle I'm starting to
really do it strong man
uh but uh I'm gonna Dodge you on that
you're too good but um gratitude and
humility this is hard the concept of
teaching someone to be more self-aware
is something I've been thinking about
for a long time you know I think the
thing that drives so many of us crazy in
the world is interacting with those that
struggle with self-awareness
I think one of the hardest things for
people to deal with is hypocrisy we
struggle with it and I struggle with it
um
the exercise in the book that I decided
to do was
creating Frameworks for the people that
know you the best
to create a safe space for them to be
able to tell you the truth
I think one of the reasons people
struggle with self-awareness is because
they have enablers around them that are
allowing them to get away with bad
behavior
and so I'm spending a lot of time trying
to think about how one puts the people
that knows them the best in a safe place
to actually give them the critical
feedback that could be the jar of a
journey towards self-awareness it's a
very tough challenge I don't know if I
have the answer what I can tell you is
no question the Business Leaders that I
admire the human beings that I admire
are the ones who are off the charts and
self-awareness I'm incredibly grateful
for the luck of the DNA game that I
think gave me a lot of it I would argue
that the only reason I have any level of
popularity is because of self-awareness
because of the kind of Communicator I am
and my personality I would be completely
not palpable if I didn't have high
levels of self-awareness because I have
some really funny attributes as a
communicator and so it's a common
conversation we need more of I do think
that self-awareness has a very
interesting relationship with
accountability
I think that a lot of people actually
know
what their shortcomings are but they try
to navigate the world
in a way where they are hoping that
people don't notice
and it's something I'm thinking a lot
about my belief is that fear is powerful
and however you were brought up or what
your ideology is on safety you put
having a job on a pedestal as something
that's secure the logic for all of us
listening to right now is if you're
making double what you make in there it
seems like a very obvious step but I'm
empathetic that you're scared to make
that jump my thing to remind you and
people out there in a similar situation
is it's not very hard to get another job
if you fail if you leave this job and so
for me if we were friends and we talked
all the time the thing I would always
remind you every day is if you take the
leap of faith and some reason it doesn't
work which by the way if you're making
double your salary as a side hustle if
you give a hundred percent of your time
to that I have a funny feeling it's
going to work out but I would remind you
that you could always go and get a job
again in the same industry maybe for a
different company believe it or not and
I've seen this sometimes for the same
company because they missed you I that's
what I would pound into your head
because whatever you grew up with it
created an ideology that a job was safe
does that make sense to you Mo yeah
absolutely guys thank you very much
listen before before you leave you need
to re-listen to that over and over and
over every human being is the byproduct
of what they listen to so if you're
listening to your parents or a plus one
or somebody else that's saying no no no
no no no don't make the jump you're not
going to make the jump if you listen to
somebody who's saying something
practical like take the jump and oh by
the way if it doesn't work you can
always go back and if it fails who cares
about other people's judgment then
you'll jump this is a very simple
business conversation
if you want to sell things it's a good
idea to make it easier for people to buy
from you
and so the Innovation is the mindset
The Innovation is going home now and
deciding what you just saw in this talk
and saying is he right or is he wrong
and if you find yourself saying he's
right but I don't want to I really mean
this that's okay
but then you have to be honest with
yourself of where you are in your career
whether that means maybe doing something
else because you don't have fire for it
or being content which is fine a
beautiful thing if you're content but
you have to be aware that this is all
happening around you I I don't have to
tell this room how much Innovation is
going on in this space you've got the
biggest technology companies in the
world interested in your money I know
what the big tech companies are doing I
know what's happening with blockchain I
know what's happening with the 20 year
olds that everybody makes fun of who are
picking up incredible market share from
a lot of you because they're actually
being seen on social they may not know
the business yet
and you love making fun of them for that
I got bad news for you that they'll
figure out
yeah no that's that's
[Laughter]
you may need to take a pause on that one
people make fun of things until they
don't
everybody made fun of the Kardashians
until they didn't
everybody made fun of Tesla until they
didn't
everybody made fun of my pictures until
they sold for a million dollars today on
Christie's congratulations
people love to make fun of things
and what I'm worried about is this
room's too successful
that's a great success is the beginning
of the end what are some of those you
know you've you've spoken candidly about
your parents and the meticulous
upbringing what are some of the things
they taught you that now even get you to
sit here and give back in such a fashion
my I think gratitude is the reason I
give back I think the single reason I
want to put out all the content and do
things like
I'm very compensated for a speech like
this but no longer does that make
Financial sense to me in my business
world it's just amazing to be here with
all of you I love it
why because I know how I communicate I
know that I come here with an agenda and
that agenda is to suffocate one person
in this room's [__]
with the hope that it's exactly what
they needed to go do something so that
in four years they could send me an
email and say I was in San Diego in 2021
and I thought I was hot [__] but then
you got me and then I got my [__]
together
then I got my [__] together and now my
family's so much better life and that
feeling for me is better than even when
I'm winning
so my my selfishness is my selflessness
it's fun for me I'm already good you
know it's very easy to give when you're
fulfilled sure right and so
for me
what happened a my family heritage was
crazy up
my mom lost her mom at five my dad lost
his dad at 16. we lived in the Soviet
Union a lot of people don't know this I
didn't realize how many people don't
know this you weren't allowed to leave
the country
the country was a prison from 1918 to
1990 a prison you weren't allowed to
leave
everybody spend time in jail because the
government owned everything Cuba and
Venezuela are a vacation compared to
Soviet Union in the 50s 60s 70s and 80s
so
you know here I am we left in 78 I'm
three years I'm growing up in America
but and this is going to really hit for
this room I'm growing up in America but
am I really because in my four walls
it's from Russia
right but but but I both right so in the
house all I'm hearing every Friday night
and on the weekends is the stories of
the old country and it's a disaster
and I'm out here drinking Coca-Cola and
watching Mickey Mouse
and so very quickly I'm just thankful
I'm just grateful and so gratitude was
big
the the other thing they taught me was
it the story looked like this sixth
grade Nintendo explodes right and I'm
like Mom Nintendo and she's like good go
get it
and so you know that framework gets you
serious about lemonade and washing cars
and shoveling snow and so my parents
taught me a level of work ethic that I
would in hindsight at 45
say it was probably too extreme the
three of us talk about it a lot I think
all of us collectively look at each
other and say maybe we took it to 130
100 would have been fine 80 would have
been fine we lived in 130 I worked from
the time I was 14. I worked every
weekend and every summer vacation day of
my life
all of them like when people hear it I
don't think they understand all of them
not like kind of you know like you meet
people they're like they helped out in
their family business every day
I was a terrible student my parents sat
me down at 14 and they're like you're
not going to Harvard so you're going to
work every day
and so so work ethic was taught and then
I had such a gift of communicating that
my father really really impacted my life
because he has no tolerance for lying
and I had an incredible ability to
manipulate everyone on Earth
and when you're young and you realize
you have Gift of Gab you have no idea
how to fully function with it right and
so
my dad really helped me because I was so
scared of him
and for my father
embellishing or a slight exaggeration
was like a death blow
he keeps it so straight and that really
helped me a lot I I I think about that a
lot I was gifted with so many things but
I it really worked out for me on how
they parented me but I but it all comes
down to gratitude when I tell you
the only thing on earth I care about is
the health of my family it is the only
thing I care about everything I do in
business is a game I don't give a [__]
like money all of it health for someone
like myself really wants to go into
entrepreneurship ultimately and like
start a business like I'm interested in
several areas like media emerging Tech
all that but I don't really know like
which specific thing I want to do would
you say to like start at like some
company first and then kind of figure it
out from there or just like kind of go
how do you learn
I I think mostly by doing so done don't
go to a company but I feel like there's
a lot of there's a lot of like
I guess pressure in a sense to like you
know go you can stop this sentence right
there
you know that you learn that way but
you're going to do something else based
on somebody else
yeah that'll make sense that's what
everyone's doing bro and so everyone's
sitting around and trying to figure out
why everybody every all these young
people are so upset it's because of all
this
because they were over coddled by a
generation of over coddling parents
and they don't know how to do their own
and I think they can do tons of [__] and
believe you can do so much as long as
you tune out
are you in a place where you're
comfortable to do what I lived through
this is I mean I lived it I lived the
world where from you know now on me
but 26 year old me
was ringing up my friends from high
school at my dad's liquor store
when they rolled in with their BMW
because they went to a good school and
started working at Goldman Sachs and
could afford one or not really but they
wanted to look like they could and they
were buying a case of Moet Shandon and I
was ringing it up for them and this is
real stories now and carrying the case
to their car and putting it in their
trunk I walked in feeling fulfilled
because I was happy I made a sale
they were leaving there feeling
unbelievable because Gary's bringing out
my case
the problem was that was just when we
were 26. now that we're 43 it's real
real real different
I just had the internal strength to deal
with that scenario 99 of you aren't Evan
thank you so much for having a couple
seconds and being able to tell the
believe Nation a little bit about
empathy wines it means a lot to me that
you would take this valuable real estate
and and time on your channel to give me
some love means a lot it's just good
karma points and so you're just you're
awesome thank you believe Nation uh if
you're into wine at all go to
empathywines.com my whole careers work
was poured into producing a wine that
rivaled 40 to 60 wine for 20 bucks a
bottle uh I'm just super excited about
this subscription-based wine business
you can order three six or 12 bottles in
subscription form Rose white red
um if you if you search on Instagram or
Twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like I don't even like
garyvee but the line's good super proud
of the effort thanks Evan for the time
uh wishing you guys all happy and
healthy
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Tom bill you
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there morning routines
are one of the most important things
that you can create in your life and the
reason is when you start the day if you
get early momentum going the rest of the
day is often going to follow in that
it's an idea called entropy